i want to ask you something you just
gave a commencement speech at tulane
university's class of 2015. that's a big
school that's a big deal
how nervous were you were you like
preparing for this thing for a long time
um
yes and no i mean yes yes and no to the
uh preparing for the long time yeah yes
very nervous it was my cousin was
graduating so it was actually like a
really wonderful reason to do i've never
done it before i know you've done it
it's a it's a really
big deal yeah it can feel like a lot of
it's funny because you can you do shows
day in day out but when you're asked to
do something like that and you feel like
i'm going to be speaking to these kids
just before they go off in the world it
feels like more pressure and also i know
they wanted comedy but i'm such a sap
that i was like well i got to get the
sincerity in there and my dad had gone
to tulane so it was like full circle it
was really like a family affair thing
but then i found out that the previous
speaker before me was the dalai lama i
was like oh no pressure right
so i was on saturday night live yeah
that seems i'm really good at sketch
comedy he can reincarnate
that was where i kind of and then the
best part about it yeah is
like when you're put to task in life you
really realize what you're made of and
i've done live television and i'm and
i'm great at improv
but uh preparing a speech i had months
to prepare but it did not stop me from
becoming the high school student i
always was which was cramming the night
before oh you you left it to the night
before well i i had a lot of jokes i
wanted to add at like 6 30 a.m like the
night before i was like i don't think
it's done
right it was really actually it was
really nerve-wracking and it was really
hard the good news is um
that i like i got to make a joke about
it so part of the speech was i was like
i was writing it in the cab on the way
here but i kind of was
were you actually like thinking while
you were watching other people speak oh
i'll switch this around or hey that's an
idea i did the horrible thing about the
internet because everything else about
the internet is perfect but the horrible
thing about the internet the only
horrible only horrible thing about the
internet was that you can see everybody
else's commencement speeches and realize
when they're in totality all said and
done like they look fantastic and
perfect right so i watched everybody
else's and then when i got to the
rehearsal uh the president of the school
said can you believe it everyone's
talking they're talking about it on cnn
and it was a picture of like who's gonna
give the best commencement speech it was
a picture of me with like a fake
graduate's cap on next to like obama and
stephen colbert
yeah i wonder who's gonna give the best
i think we all know it's not the lady
that's not true i don't mean because i'm
a lady i mean because i'm me
like i was standing next to the
president yeah but do you yeah i heard
it went really well i didn't get the tip
but i heard it really well it actually
went really great and it was really fun
because
tulane um graduation is in the superdome
so i got to like perform in this
superdome how cool was that it was
amazing they also because it's tulane so
it's new orleans they also serve beer at
the graduation what
i've done wait a minute
so humane don't be made that's what
education the crowd
the crowd goes wild it's at 10 a.m
that's fantastic so like you see people
with their cups so the year before was
the dalai lama like yeah
[Laughter]